[Music]
what's up mkbhd here
sony wh-1000xm4
these are those
and you couldn't tell just by looking at
them because they look almost identical
to the mark iii's from the last
generation
but that's totally fine because no one
really had any major complaints with the
mark iii's
at least i didn't i crowned them my
active noise cancellation kings but now
here they are these are the mark fours
they are the same price 349 and sony
smartly took the if it ain't broke don't
fix it approach and basically just
addressed all the small little requests
that people like me had with the last
generation it's like they lined up all
their little nitpicks and knocked them
all down so okay what was left to
improve well number one my biggest
request was multiple device support and
it took them two years but they finally
did it and they've added multiple device
support to the mark iv so the ability to
pair these headphones actively to more
than one device at once it might sound
like kind of a niche thing but it's such
a big deal if you have your headphones
paired to your computer and your phone
at the same time or your tablet and your
phone at the same time you're listening
to music on one thing you get a phone
call on the other and it just seamlessly
automatically switches then you hang up
and go back to music and it switches
back it's just so much better of an
experience than going into bluetooth
settings unpairing then repairing
manually every time so that's number one
and it's actually been improving over
time when i first got these headphones
it didn't really work very well at all
but they've been getting software
updates and through the sony app they've
gotten better so it's fixed itself up
over time and we'll probably continue to
get updates and hopefully keep getting
better in the future so with that by
itself to be honest they probably could
have stopped there and i would have been
happy that's all i really wanted but
number two they also made the noise
cancellation
better than on the mark iii's
now i crown the mark iii as my active
noise cancellation kings because the
noise cancellation and sound quality was
so good on them that i picked them over
better looking better feeling
cooler headphones like the surface
headphones
because of it
and this is better so the mark iv is
again sound incredible super clean and
bright and full with all the same noise
cancellation controls in the sony app
like before all your eq settings but now
the noise cancellation cancels out
slightly more of some higher frequencies
too so it's always been amazing with low
frequency homes stuff like airplanes and
trains and rumbles that you've already
known but now with things like
dishwashers and cars and even people's
voices it cancels more of those out too
now i can't necessarily tell a
difference immediately between the
threes and the fours as far as noise
cancellation it's not like a reason to
buy the force but i did notice that
typing on my mechanical keyboard which
has brown switches the clacking was
generally canceled out really well and
bottom line here is you're not going to
find a better pair of noise cancellation
headphones just as far as pure isolation
and sound quality so if there's a better
one out there i haven't found it yet
it's like being in another dimension
sometimes there's also technically some
very slight physical adjustments to the
dimensions too the cushions are 10
larger so that's technically an
improvement and also if you look inside
the left ear cup you'll see a proximity
sensor and that's for the wear detection
feature that i'll get to in a second but
actually believe it or not this helps me
find which was the left and right ear
cup a little faster but the one that
really matters is the new mics so the
mark iv now has a better mic pattern
with five microphones for better call
quality and better voice recognition so
i've never really thought the microphone
quality of wireless headphones was that
amazing to begin with like as long as
they work you can hear my voice that's
fine but these actually have five
microphones built into them now which is
an improvement and so apparently they
can cancel out background noise is
better you can hear my voice a little
bit more isolated so as long as that's
true then that's also nice if you fire
up the sony app there's again some nice
convenient features in here enabled by
the sensors and mics on the headphones
you may never use these or you may be
like me and use some of them some of the
time but i'll go in order of coolest to
most gimmicky here so wear detection is
unique to the mark fours thanks to the
added sensor in the left ear cup so with
that in the sony headphones app you can
tell it to pause music when you take the
headphones off and turn the headphones
off after they've been off of your head
for a while to save battery which is
smart you can also now while the music
is playing put your hand over the right
ear cup like that and it will drop the
music way down turn noise cancellation
off pass through and amplify voices
so in theory if you want to talk to
someone while keeping the headphones on
you don't want to have to do the whole
on off thing you can just pull one of
these
and you're talking to someone i think
that's maybe useful sometimes on public
transit or on an airplane if we ever get
to do that again
if you just want to talk to someone real
quick but as soon as you take your hand
off the music comes right back and the
noise cancellation is back on and you're
right where you left off so that's all
right and it's fast like i think that
makes a big difference to actually using
the feature if i put my hand there and
you have to wait a second for it to kick
in that would be kind of disappointing
as soon as i put my hand there boom i'm
listening to people but then maybe the
most gimmicky feature is the speak to
chat function
which basically will use the mics and i
guess other sensors in the headphone to
be able to tell when i start speaking
and when i do start speaking it will
pause my music
turn off noise cancellation and amplify
voices
so i'm wearing the headphones listening
to music i start talking it pauses the
music and now i'm having a conversation
through the headphones and i guess
that's
fine it works
it was surprisingly effective at not
accidentally doing it when i wasn't
talking
but you know if someone walks up to me
and starts talking i go what and then
the music pauses and then i'm talking to
them
now the music is paused and i have to
play it again or go back into the
settings to turn the noise cancellation
back on and you can you can tell it in
the settings to turn that automatically
off after 15 seconds 30 seconds or 60
seconds but generally this wasn't a
feature i found myself wanting to use
very much so you can turn it on but i
turned it off overall though these are
basically my ideal headphones you know i
think the design could be cooler if it
had dials on the side like the surface
headphones or maybe some more cool
colors like a matte red or something
like that but generally this same matte
black understated design is totally fine
with me the same touch pad on the side
that's cool the same google assistant or
amazon alexa trigger from the custom
button on the bottom it's fine the same
case they came with is also fine i have
a designated place in my backpack for
them and there's just really nothing
fundamentally wrong with these
headphones at all and i very much
appreciate that about them so it's
pretty clear these are great and they're
easy to recommend but a nice bonus of
these existing now is that the mark
threes i've seen on sale as low as about
250 bucks so i'll leave a link to those
below as well they again won't have
multi-point support so if you don't need
two paired things at once this could be
a nice discount i'll have that linked
below but again the mark iv is pretty
sick so thank you sony for making this
such an easy review
thank you to the histogram t-shirt for
sponsoring this video
shop.mkbhd.com
and thank you
for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace